[Musique]
dois-je faire confiance au gouvernement
c'est la question que se posent des
milliers de jeunes israéliens réunis
chaque samedi dans les rues de jérusalem
depuis plus de neuf mois
oh
entre fierté nationale et scepticisme la
date du 23 mars cocher dans le
calendrier d'une partie de la population
en colère contre sens premier ministre
benyamin nétanyahou
notre premier ministre n'arrête pas de
dire qu'il est le meilleur et qu'israël
se trouve dans une situation tellement
bonne que tout va bien mais nous ne
sommes pas bien il est corrompu et ils
profitent juste de son statut de premier
ministre il est où le monde en
quarantaine pour pouvoir échapper à sa
peine je suis ici pour renverser
benyamin nétanyahou nous sommes ici
depuis l'été en espérant que ça et mieux
en israël benyamin nétanyahou pointé du
doigt pour ses ennuis judiciaires
le premier ministre est inculpé en
novembre 2019 pour corruption fraude et
abus de confiance dans trois affaires
accusation qu'il a de nouveau rejeté en
février dernier
les auditions des témoins sont attendus
le 5 avril prochain
l'image du chef du gouvernement qui
semble être écornée al'approche de
nouvelles élections législatives
mais netanyahou 71 ans en poste depuis
2009 jouit toujours d'une grande
popularité
pour preuve les bons chiffres de la
campagne de vaccination kovy 19 ce qu'un
seul au but c'est une formidable
réussite pour l'état d'israël
en fait le premier pays à sortir du
grenat virus nous avons réussi à faire
vacciner environ un million d'adultes de
plus de 16 ans nous estimons qu'à la fin
du mois d'avril
nous aurons vacciner tout le monde ce
qui signifie que nous n'avons plus de
coronavirus acharnement à couronnes 1
100 millions plus de la moitié de la
population vaccinée et des sondages en
faveur du premier ministre et de son
parti le likoud en compétition avec
l'opposant centriste et yaïr lapid
pour former un gouvernement le vainqueur
du scrutin doit obtenir 61 sièges au
parlement
les alliances sont essentiels avec
certes un petit parti qui espère faire
leur entrée au sein de la knesset en
obtenant plus de 3 25% des suffrages
c'est la première fois dans les
élections israéliennes de ces deux
dernières années que nous avons des
premières campagnes contre netanyahou
venant de la droite dure donc c'est ça
qui est différent et donc si netanyahu
doit créer une coalition
cela signifie que ce seront que les
droitiers les plus extrémistes quiero
avec netanyahu cette fois ci le destin
les regards sont notamment tourné vers
l'ex ministre de la défense naftali
bennet chef de la formation de droite
radicale yamina et n'ayant pas encore
choisi deux camps les résultats du parti
de benny gantz seront aussi scrutés
l'ex chef d'état major de l'armée et
adversaires de netanyahou aux dernières
élections en chute dans les sondages